déjà est ce que tu es heureux de tout ce
qui s'est passé et de ton score alors
jusque là non parce que je voulais être
président mais c'est bien de venir mais
sans haie mais j'étais en pleine forme
j'ai une équipe et j'ai un beau projet
et la france est très mal voilà de la
campagne heureusement que j'ai tout est
le moyen que j'ai trouvé une portée à
trois semaines à qui m un bon coup des
ports comme lino ventura 1 pour y
rentrer par effraction
1 c'est le jour du congrès des maires
jamais je n'avais vu autant
d'éditorialistes réunis chez moi je
m'empare aux journalistes qui comme tout
le monde essaie de gagner sa vie un
surplus là il fait tout ce que j'ai et
là je n'avais jamais vu autant de gros
ensembles dont je leur ai dit que nous
étions des lâches nous les politiques
qui devenait aussi lâche que non et moi
j'ai été très maltraité pendant cette
campagne je ne sais pas pourquoi on
analyse c'est un petit carnet là je veux
qu'elles doivent attacher à 3% je te
jure que moi je trouve que tu es un des
grands gagnants de 2,2 de l'élection
c'est sûr que c'est vrai et et jean 3%
ne crois pas à ça va compter est-ce que
tu as eu des appels ou des manuels
maquereau ou de marine le pen n'ont pour
l'instant pas tu as toujours un
téléphone
il a du retard non je veux te dire
guerre au cours de vos jeux chez tu sais
pas pas répondu c'est dur mais un
million cent mille votes et un million
sont il va te rends compte que ça en est
ce que tout le monde que c'est mais je
les remercie du fond du coeur parce que
c'est des visionnaires et que vois je
moi j'ai 66 en général tu vas te
représenter dans cinq ans
si tu as raison de la il avait cette
année un recul sur le court je veux pas
une très haute idée de la face je fais
très haute idée des institutions de
notre grand pays notre grand pays avait
besoin d'être rassemblée précisément
somme en jeu quand je pourrai le faire
j'étais le seul à pouvoir faire c'est
d'être mini vernement le seul but
premier ministre d'emmanuel macro ça ne
sert à rien break ministre un nom chez
chirac aurait proposé deux fois voilà
nos deux fois proposé via ce qui se
souvient des ministres qui sont passés à
sa fin il y en a quelques-uns de s'en
souvient sens et pénis afin de villepin
a oui mais j'étais punie ça n'est pas un
bon ministre ne nie pas mais les autres
tu vas avoir du mal à l'appel d'offres
avant miss a servi du temps où il y
avait de l'argent dans l'espace public
ou prouvé il ya plus hideux va me parler
de liberté et de fraternité où on
pouvait parler aussi de service public à
la française on n'avait pas des hôpitaux
à l'africom et harbin où on n'avait pas
fermé des postes partout moi j'avais un
projet pour embaucher 100 mille
infirmières ou aides soignantes parce
que à mon avis il y a il n'ya qu'à lire
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen et on comprend il y a de quoi
un être sacré c'est l'homme depuis le
moment où in our ce son premier soupir
juste son dernier il ne devrait pas être
un produit mach amnésie